[Music]
and don't limit yourself news submitted
by what the Fox say an executive coach
says the idea of making yourself
indispensable is terrible career choice
[Music]
that's indispensable right there [ __ ]
BAM why I can't do what he just did
oh I see yeah you can't throw this away
it can't be replaced I think we can get
like a little monkey to sit here
probably fear that uh-oh he'd be so much
better you'd be good at it
sorry I this dispensable I guess oh yeah
yeah good point yes I retire they're
saying here that that's like the worst
career career advice you could give
because when you make yourself
indispensable that's the best way to
keep yourself where you are in your job
rather I have to disagree if you don't
ask for more maybe oh yeah I completely
disagree
no I completely disagree I think that
making yourself indispensable is a
safety net that's what people aspire to
yeah basically in a job that doesn't
have tenure be dispensable should happen
we need to do a [ __ ] like you know we
need to [ __ ] start firing some people
you know what let's let's not fire the
indispensable people we'll fire the
people that are dispensable definition
of be indispensable that you're really
good at one thing like if that's your
[ __ ] then stay there cuz then you're
never gonna grow to anything more what
they're saying here it's fine all that
it dispensed a thirteen year old kid who
plays xbox write this I kind of backed
us up even though is making fun of it
because I was such a bad ass [ __ ]
busboy I was the killer top dog dad you
know what ended up happening didn't get
promoted to waiter they wanted to keep
me as possible yeah and that's the exact
example they're using here
no one wanted other Busboys they're like
no no no I keep keep drilling there cuz
the waiters wanted like me on the staff
I'm all like [ __ ] you guys man and then
well they would share their tip with me
more than the other guys but still it's
like I make big money making yourself
indispensable is leverage for asking for
a raise but yes it is because you could
threaten them you could extort them with
your skills you could be like what this
other place we're gonna
me anyway yeah but I was gonna leave but
I really like staying here yeah who is
her career coach so this is some
unemployed journalist this is on courts
on courts no no no courts calm it's uh
what's it about rocks so no yeah so what
they're saying here is that the key to
be indispensable is to be indispensable
for what you can become
and not for what you currently do and
there are four ways to do that one is
help others see you in a different light
so show people that there's more than
one dimension to your capabilities so if
they mostly see you doing
behind-the-scenes research invite them
to a meeting where you're on stage
presenting take on new challenges let
others know you have in you have the
interest and potential to do more
how could you demonstrate you can learn
and grow beyond your current role this
still sounds being dispensable yeah yeah
exactly
so the number two is see yourself in a
different light the longer you stay in
the comfort zone of the role where
you're indispensable the harder it will
be to envision yourself doing something
else and that will color your behavior
instead challenge yourself to see
yourself in a different light look for
opportunities where you can learn
stretch and develop new capabilities
what does you 2.0 look feel and sound
like that sounds like being
indispensable to number three prepare
for the next level the best way to do
this is to continually invest in
yourself and your developments make time
to learn new things identify the
experiences and skills you want to have
talk to others about what it takes and
the things they wish they've done to
prepare themselves then go explore how
you can do those things
what would prepare you for the next
level in your career and the last one is
make yourself movable building a bench
of talent beneath you is the best way to
ensure that senior managers feel
comfortable moving you to the next level
position you aspire to remember you
don't want to end up like
indispensable Steve what your
indispensable could step into you move
up if you can create your own backfill
managers won't feel as anxious promoting
you because they're talking about a
story here similar to what Joe was
saying where like they remember
overhearing a manager saying no no no
keep Steve there like he's perfect where
he is
and he got passed up for promotion so
someone else got a promotion because he
was so indispensable in that position
and that's really what they're focusing
on here is like when you can't move up
in your career because you're being
pigeon-holed I think what they're
talking about is also like one-trick
ponies what I've seen is especially in
the social media space that people that
have proven themselves to be
indispensable they prove themselves so
well with leadership that's when
leadership moves don't don't poach
people you know when people trying to
assemble this new super team they're
like okay I remember the marketing guy
from this place this guy from this place
and they'll just start pulling people
together into this new super group in
this new company so for me and I think
being indispensable is a good thing
because your work ethic and their
ability to adapt and how much how
well-rounded you are it really impresses
people people really want you to be a
part of their team wherever they go
people like this where they're like okay
I'm gonna just keep you down here that
means there's problem with with
management cuz if you're a leader can't
move up and you can't move up with your
leader your leaders not growing like if
your leader is the one that's passing up
the promotion that's like what that
means he's not getting promoted because
you should be going like this if your
leaders it also depends on like how they
communicate it because some people just
wait for that promotion instead of
saying like hey I love this job and and
I know I'm good at what I'm doing like
in sales but I rather be in marketing
and so you've got to continuously remind
your manager or the [ __ ] HR of
whoever it is to say like yeah that's
that's where my trajectory is I want to
eventually go there and if I can't
fulfill myself in this company doing
that then I can do that somewhere else
I'm eventually gonna do marketing
somewhere else this article was written
for beta's it was yes oh yeah and then
people that you know they take one word
and then they misinterpret it because I
think everything needs that explanation
like I wouldn't tell someone not to be
indispensable because my idea of how to
approach work is learn it from [ __ ]
back front up side to side do be the
[ __ ] best and and and like learn that
task and when someone tells you don't be
indispensable what it what it sounds
like to me is like it sounds like be a
half-ass er because when it's really
your time to shine when you get to that
department then you [ __ ] go all out
and I'm like you should go all out every
single day of your life when you're in
the workplace it's as easy as talking to
your manager and saying I want to move
to that department yeah
know your value that's what I found out
yeah the [ __ ] this is this is [ __ ] for
people who don't understand like it's
like I'll be the best busboy ever but
never say you want to be a waiter yeah I
eventually became a waiter right and I
was held in that position but it also
got to the point where you get I guess
seniority right you you you know you
become that that that what do you call
it you becoming you become a good
bargain chip is what it is and then me
and my coworkers who are like killer in
what we did at the restaurant we became
indispensable as a part of the team so
then the more powerful you become the
more what's the word you you have more
say in your position you could like I
just want the best hours that pays me
the best I want this I want that they'll
be like sure take it off take it dude
look at today nobody wants to do the job
we beg people to host it's like you know
oh no no I'm just saying like you you
it's just it's just it can be stressful
to do that
it's an indispensable though you made
yourself indispensable where it's like I
wanted to kick you out so many [ __ ]
times but I can't because I need her
here and she keeps the process so
[ __ ] complex only she can understand
his [ __ ] computer every time that iOS
they have to put some graphic on top of
the screen if I'm doing something
because I probably [ __ ] it up giggles
three fingers this way as the photos two
fingers this way as this and the one
finger down she's like it if you want
the computer turn on you gotta go like
this looking for the four to the day
that I host it's gonna be very
interesting
oh yeah that's coming up you can see it
on our patreon you gotta go to patreon
for that though Bart already hosted yep
you decide on that one out of you what's
going to happen are you just gonna host
a [ __ ] screensaver that turns in a
different thing right up to see the
article gonna change during the [ __ ]
okay it's exciting Wow they're also
saying that manager
that tell you every time you go in for
your caps creation advice for you
they're trying to give you like
well-meaning advice which is like you're
doing a great job just keep doing what
you're doing how [ __ ] managers are
either too nice or too lazy to come up
with feedback that will actually help
you develop so yeah it's it's a whole
game man and I um it's been a while
since I worked like uh like a regular
job meaning like you know whether it's
like in a service industry or corporate
or whatever but there is a lot of human
maneuvering that's going on like when
you're working for yourself where you're
working with equals or if you're working
in a group where it's like everyone kind
of comes together in a collaborative
effort that's very different because
everyone's coming together to cash out
together it's it's different from a
corporate setting where like half of
that [ __ ] is politics mm-hmm
I saw a lot of brown nosing going on and
and that's how people get results and
they get [ __ ] um you know they don't
care about skills they don't care about
hard work sometimes it's like oh he's my
favorite yeah it's not even how good you
are at your job it's how well you can
play the game in the corporate ladder
yeah dude in a lot of people get work
too and they don't even know they're
getting work but somebody sucks their
ass so [ __ ] hard and they're like wow
I really like this person yeah I can't
quite put my finger on why it's like
this yeah your ass all the way oh
there's like 12 vice president sometimes
dude they [ __ ] give them enemas
through their own [ __ ] I've seen
crazy see I've seen that [ __ ] yeah like
stop making it so visualize oh I wish
they didn't do it yeah I mean people
like dude people [ __ ] their way into it
or like there's just like scandals like
man I I'm so glad I'm not a part of that
world anymore it's so [ __ ] [ __ ] man
sorry if you're still partner but all
I'm saying is you got a game they watch
this to escape and then they're back in
it I know you got a game it though you
got a game it is if you do want to grow
you gotta be indispensable and that's
like one of the things I tell interns
are people that are like potentially
trying to apply for it all of the stuff
that we do it's like you you got to make
yourself indispensable you come part of
the team and then like oh [ __ ] like this
guy is a coal bureau on the broad and I
can see how much under how much
underperforming would be if they weren't
part of a team and I'll try to figure
out a way to make this person salary
yeah and then in addition to being a
dispensable also just be a go-getter
like be everywhere wants like make sure
you're seeing like don't just wait for
people to tell you to do [ __ ] and then
do it don't treat it like it's cool
taking it sorry my thing about taking
initiative like that is I don't want to
overstep boundaries and do something
that I wasn't supposed to do so I've
I've always wanted to be a go-getter but
I also get anxiety about doing things
without being told to do so before
having to you know what I I think every
time I work somewhere give it about two
weeks and I hate everybody that that's
there because I don't like inefficiency
I don't like yeah stupid people
I hate lazy co-workers that are making
my work harder because of them so I try
to get people fired Oh take over the
manager's job and I try to come in and
I'm like oh yeah and I'm like you know
what this is if this was my company
that's how I would approach it if this
was my company I would do it this way
and I just keep trying to fix it fix it
and I don't like the problems and I
don't like sitting there being lazy so I
guess I have a totally different
mentality but give it gives me some time
in a company and I've always approached
it that way two weeks I hate everybody
for me I'm similar to you where I'm like
I don't want to like like like make
anyone feel bad but also because I hate
inefficiency I'm always creating my own
systems for things that work for me and
then I'm like okay then I'm like well I
tried it this way you know what I mean
so I feel like there's still a way to go
about it I don't know for me it's it I I
take seniority very very seriously like
even if it's not the politics yeah
exactly so my thing is I'm going to be
demure until I have earned my place here
so you tell me everything you want me to
do and I will always do it but I'm not
it's not that I'm not going to do more
than I've been asked it's that I'm not
going to overstep gotcha that make sense
that's true cuz if I want set and
somebody random says something that I'd
never seen before my eyes kind of glaze
over and I'm like I don't give a [ __ ]
but if it's like somebody who's like oh
I know I respect my own [ __ ] I'm like oh
yeah that's true oh that's interesting
yeah that's what you just got to do the
work for them and be like damn boss
you're [ __ ] genius they're like
do that oh yeah you did any mine [ __ ]
and many [ __ ] work do you have to
consent to that oh my [ __ ] you do I
don't think you do legally I [ __ ] you
by doing your job for you
[Music]